[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to another episode of
Whata Prof hello Walter hello
Martin well at least your smile tells me
you're not doing as you just answered oh
am I in a better place than you thought
yes I'm very very happy to hear it can
you send me
details well didn't we do one a few
while back about smiling or where did
you do that one about smiling you you
can use six muscles or 40 something yes
so let's let's brighten the
smiles with the fullon muscles yes yes
well we're talking about relevance
right you can pack a lot of into
relevance you can basically make that
title and and talk about many many
things but we want to talk about
relevant
things important relevant things yes
things well shall we get into it I think
we must pray let's
pray our heavenly
father once again it's an important
subject and we ask that you bless our
discussion Enlighten everybody's Minds
including ours and guide us through this
so that your name can be glorified in
Jesus name amen
amen
relevance and this relevance is not
going
anywhere this relevance has been around
for 6,000 years and before that for an
eternity
but uh Martin it's not going
anywhere and whenever people leave the
path of
relevance they go through very difficult
times and they have to be led back to
the path of relevance then they lose it
again mhm and so it goes on so actually
what you're saying is with the word re
relevance the word remember goes
along and Martin the relevance we're
going to talk about is the centrality of
Christ there is a tendency in the
world to reject the
Cornerstone mhm the religious systems in
the
world put tradition in the place of the
Cornerstone they they call it by the
same names some of
them but uh do they acknowledge the
relevance of the
claims because there's a kingdom right
and the kingdom is not of this world and
if you are Redeemed by the blood of the
Lamb then you become a subject of that
Kingdom then you are in this world but
you're not of this
world now if we look at the times in
which we are
living it takes me back
to a time when baby was about to
fall isn't that the second Angel's
message yes all right isn't there a loud
repeat of it in Revelation chapter 18
come out over my people MH that you be
not part of her
plagues and part of her
sins well Martin there was a time when
King belasa was having a party right
yeah and his kingdom that night was
about to fall and he was about to lose
his
life and a hand appeared and Route
against the
wall he didn't have a
clue what it was about the writing on
the wall he just knew it was ominous and
his knees smoked
together but he didn't know what it
meant right
yeah I'm afraid Martin that the writings
on the wall and many many people even
those that should know haven't got a
clue who what it says
no so why did the writing appear what
was his final Act of
apostasy he called for the cups yeah
from God God's cups from the
temple and he put common wine in
them Martin can you serve common wine in
the vessels of the Lord no is there
somewhere in the Bible we we read about
the wine of Babylon yes in Revelation
and don't the kings of the world drink
it and become
drunk that's 100% Revelation and what is
that wine that they're drinking and the
wine is false Doctrine right is it
possible that church members that should
know better could embibe from this wine
yes claiming to hold the the the cup of
the Lord
mhm do you think it's possible
I don't even think it's possible it has
to be because Bible says it will be like
this now why do these people not know
what the writing on the wall says who
did they have to get to tell them what
it meant
prophets a
prophet they had to get old Daniel right
tell me what this means what's this many
take what does this mean he didn't have
a clue yeah that his kingdom had been
weighed in the balance in other words a
judgment had taken place yeah where did
that judgment take place in heaven oh
must have been in heaven right
yeah are we are we getting to see some
Parables I hope people are seeing this
if you don't I think it's time to study
okay all right
so people looked at the writing and they
said what is that what is that I think
there are people in the
church even those that keep the
Commandments of God and hold to the
testimony oh no let's rephrase that that
think they hold keep the Commandments
but don't hold to the testimony they
haven't got a prophet to tell them what
it means no because they thrown out the
testimony so what's this writing on the
wall I have no no
idea and if they want to get a prophet
to tell them it's more like that guy
that said I've got 400 prophets and then
they said but isn't there a Prophet of
the Lord around
yes he is but I hate him because he's
speaking negative towards he he's saying
what I don't want to
hear Martin if we don't understand the
signs of the times we'll never read the
writing on the
wall and if we don't listen and take
heed to what the prophets have to
say then we will never understand very
important so we are living in very very
troubless times
and what are the
issues is the message about the
centrality of
Christ still relevant absolutely what
about the abrahamic Accord that's why
it's so important because everything
will start looking
excellent what's missing in the
abrahamic Accord
Christ oh they all have a um Abraham yes
but Christ is not there no no one
professors that is there but is in
Alliance with two that don't no two that
actually totally negate him and the
atonement yeah you see the one that is
actually supposed to be aligned with the
centrality of Christ has so far put him
aside that he's not there anymore all
right
right can I ask you another question
Martin how many problems does the world
face at the
moment how many
problems actually not that many anymore
because they've got a savior now there's
a peacemaker all right there's a
peacemaker but why are the kings of the
world having secret meetings to try and
figure out why they're not invited to
the table there's so many problems that
it's impossible to sort that out but
Martin can't you focus on at least one
and make that your life
mission what about all the hungry people
in the world is it our duty to be kind
to the to the hungry people in the world
definitely okay must you do what you can
yes
okay uh what
about not only hungry people but all the
homelessness in the
world what about those that are not
homeless and are poverty
stricken what about areas with
disease what about
social
upheavals what about the
climactic
disasters what about Gaza
what about
Sudan what about
Ukraine uh what about South Africa what
about South
Africa Martin we what about racism mhm
what about religious
controversy what about
wokeness you shouldn't have thrown that
one in you you defunded
all right so would you say there are
lots of bandwagons that you can climb on
for sure
okay now the centrality of
Christ when Christ walked on this
Earth was he a thorn in the flesh of
some yeah definitely is that is that why
he ended up with the crown of thorns for
sure do you know that was was a
coronation without them knowing it yeah
that whole ceremony basically was a
coronation all right and
then when he was resurrected and went to
heaven and the disciples were fired up
through the Holy
Spirit they were very popular
right they paid with it with their lives
didn't Herod please the Pharisees by
putting some in jail and killing some
yeah that was very pleasing to
them all right so what were they at odds
about wasn't that the centrality of
Christ was the centrality of Christ
right they told
Peter not to preach in that name all
right and uh the kings of the world does
the Bible say they were a raid against
the Messiah yeah the kings were a raid
we discussed that last time remember all
the kings were arrayed against him and
the Bible at the end says the kings of
the world will gather themselves for the
great
battle and they will Master their forces
in the end again to be ar raay against
him in the form of his people and his
what he stands for is that what the
Bible says yes okay so he has a question
now if Christ is the Central Point
around which all these controversies are
raging then do you think the
churches and the big churches in
particular will be somehow in the middle
of this discussion definitely definitely
right they have to be especially when
you get to the portion in Revelation
where it tells you that apostate
protestantism will join up with the all
right so they will join up now let's go
to
protestantism when Christ was
removed subtly so that nobody should
notice
it and an Earthly pontificate was put in
the place thereof so that you look
towards the pontificate for guidance and
no longer to the word of God did that
become a bone of contention yes wasn't
one of the the catchphrases of the
Reformation solar
mhm Christ Alone Christ and Christ
alone all
right and wasn't that a point of
contention that he was
alive and therefore the mass seemed
obsolete because how can you have a mass
of a of a constant death yeah if he was
once sacrificed for all
time and why would you need an
intermediary like a priest
M if the petition was gone and you had
Direct access to the throne of God
through
him and that was the pillars and where
the pro the Reformation the
protestantism was B brought about okay
so again were there wars fought mhm
because of the centrality of Christ yes
did the reformers identify the papacy as
Antichrist yes one or two of them right
no no all all of
them okay on the basis of what scripture
scripture okay so would you say that in
the time of the decline of the Jewish
Kingdom before its
destruction Christ was the pivot around
which everything revolved and the
destruction of Jerusalem was a direct
result of the rejection of Christ
definitely because the whole Jewish
system was built around him the whole
sacrifice they pointed to him everything
pointed to him all right but they
rejected him yes thank God not all
yes okay do you think the the Christian
world can reach the same point for the
sake of convenience
yes and that's also scriptural that's
also scriptural
okay so were there wars fought over this
centrality yeah many many right many I
think how much blood has been shed
because of this
centrality much right Millions okay all
right that just has a little bit of a
background now I think it's important
that you um brought this out so the
importance has to be realized because
from what we are going to discuss now
it's always coming back to how important
the relevance of the cality of Christ is
okay all right now I don't want to
belabor the
point but uh how much was involved in
the cality of Christ in the
Reformation was it just put him back in
the middle or was it a a wide spectrum
of the rejection
of traditions that had been brought in
that made Christ's Ministry meaningless
a whole system was actually wared
against because of their Traditions okay
can you pray to deceased people no so
can you pray to Saints and to Mary no
isn't that necromancy praying to the
dead isn't it something that God forbade
completely okay so it's not only the
mass it's the whole system the whole
system how many mediators are there then
or
intercessors hundreds hundreds thousands
thousands and the Bible says there's
only one intercessor so this is all
rather confusing
right okay so the point I'm making we
trying to make is this centrality this
relevance
has never gone away no and it's always
been subject to attack and War for sure
all right now when the reformers had
clearly defined who the Antichrist was
and why not only from the
doctrines but by clear prophetic
guidelines in the Bible
clear could it be ever imagined that
they would turn their back on that view
and adopt a spous counterfeit Doctrine
to replace
it no you cannot actually think that it
should happen what about preterism and
futurism two Jesuit doctrines wasn't
supposed to even affect it they don't
make any biblical
sense in fact they are based on nothing
but
misinformation they cannot be upheld
with the Bible except with with very
loud preaching and no substance
yeah and lots of drums and music to
replace cognitive thinking that's the
only way you can get round the issue
right doesn't it mean a total rejection
of Daniel chapter 2 Daniel chapter 7
Daniel chapter 8 and Daniel chapter 9 it
does doesn't it mean a total rejection
of the reformers view of reev chapter
133 yeah at
least with uh regard to the first piece
because the second one wasn't even there
when the Reformation was ongoing and
this thing is once you do that it means
that the Antichrist actually can change
it can go to something or someone else
it can change but the Bible says that
the man of sin in other words the man
who stands behind the transgression of
God's law let's make that quite plain
sin is the transgression of the law
according to 1 John chapter 3 right yeah
so the man of sin is the man who stands
behind the transgression of God's law
and the authoritative transgression or
changing of God's law is an affront to
the authority of
God that's the issue we discussed last
time in our last
discussion all right
now if you want to climb onto an
ecumenical
bandwagon then would you have to wave
prophecy well let's just make it plain
what does that mean what does it mean to
get on an ecumenical bandwagon all right
if you say that that which are defined
as the enemy of God because of the
change of the law and the changing of
times and all the other features
involved and the negation of scripture
in the process I would rather for the
sake of Peace throw all of that into the
wastepaper basket and align myself even
accept them as primate in my religious
uh
organizations and again follow the lead
of the man of
sin that means a total negation of
Prophecy
so and what is the use then in believing
that in the first place all right let me
ask you another question is the pope a
king yes he's a king oh for sure cuz
he's crowned right yeah and his
Cardinals they are princes yeah so if
you swear relgions to that Prince aren't
you uh denying the relevance and the
centrality of Christ yes because if you
have become part of the kingdom of of
God then who's your
lawgiver Christ who's your Redeemer yes
who forgives you your sins only
God who Bears your sins God Jesus in
Catholicism who Bears your sins you do
you do you have to go and work pay for
them you have to pay for them so if
Catholicism denies the
atonement then they have removed the
relevance of Christ yeah so this is the
issue yes because now you bring that
into if you want to get on an ecumenical
bandwagon you have to negate some of
these things to work for the greater
good with the other one and if the
writing appears on the wall and you
negate The
Profit then you you be walking like a
blind man without a stick and without a
guide dog that's it and you will be lost
you will be lost right now Mar is it
possible that people even within our own
ranks
could come up with such ideas yes
unfortunately do we have whole
organizations that come up with these
ideas definitely so let's just have a
look at some of these things that are
coming out so that we can discuss the
times we are living in now let me make
it quite plain I'm not here to attack
any
organization or any individual I'm here
to attack a theology that's it right we
always tackle that it's it's the issue
that's involved we seldom name names the
reason being and we've made it very
plain that if you put a name to the
theology or the problem then you think
once that person is removed the problem
is solved yes but then there's just
another guy you have to address this the
the problem and anyone that qualifies to
fall under that is automatically guilty
it's part of the problem now I am not
advocating at any stage that any of
these organizations be removed from the
planet or closed down no I think they
serve an important
purpose uh because an an organization
like Adventist today for example is a
very useful organization in my opinion
because if you want to know what not to
believe that's a good source to go and
study would you age M I agree or am I a
little bit harsh in my I testimony well
if we look at the material that some of
them themselves or people that they
sponsor comes out and especially against
our um Ministry then I don't think
you're harsh at all all right I'm not
talking about their Ministry or anything
I'm talking about that their thinking
and their theology yeah so uh this came
out in August
2024 that's at the end of last year so
it's it's relatively up to dat as to
what their thinking is and the question
they are asking are Adventists
anti-catholic
bigots uh he could have left that last
word out by the way because
automatically he's saying that anyone
who is anti-catholic is a bigot exactly
so they're making a a negative
immediately immediately now
uh I am not
anti-catholic I was a Catholic
myself my half of my family are Catholic
I am definitely not anti Catholic but
I'm definitely anti- Catholicism correct
definitely because they negate the
centrality and the relevance of Christ
the doctrines it's the doctr the system
and if you have that opinion does that
automatically make you a bigot or does
it make you someone that has studied the
subject and decided that you cannot go
along with that mode of thinking the
Bible says the same so I believe what
the Bible says so was Martin Luther
according to this title then do you
think according to them a bigot when he
was definitely anti- Catholicism and
then by definition probably yes he was a
all his best friends were Catholics he
was a Catholic priest and then they
changed
right officially
yes and then they say time to come clean
we do not nearly believe that our church
is the one we think is right nor even
that ours is the only true church at the
very heart of our eschatology is the
teaching that the Roman Catholic Church
is almost supernaturally powerful and
irredeemably evil the enemy of God and
in League with the
devil now the scripture says the dragon
gave him his seat and his power and
great Authority why he must be in League
with the devil does that mean that every
Catholic knows that he is in League with
the devil no still once again it's not a
person it's not a person it's a
system do you think that if you speak to
the a average Catholic that he will know
that Catholicism negates the atonement
no no won know no they won't have a clue
they won't have a clue they won't
know uh would they think that the
changing of the Commandments is a
reality or wouldn't they even know about
it they wouldn't know about it although
it's clearly in the catechism but they
won't know about it no all right just
mentioning that do you just leave them
then no you have to inform them the the
best thing that ever happened to me and
the worst thing that ever happened to me
at at the same time was finding
out that the system was in League with
the devil
yeah and is of course it's a shock but
this is what you want to hear have they
ever changed their doctrines no have
they modified it in any way have they
rescinded any of it not one iota okay
some of the same things that
anti-semites said about Jews we
Adventists say in books we hold dear
about Roman Catholics now he's he's
implying one particular book yeah but
we'll come to that uh many
many they didn't know what that meant
until the prophet came and told them now
he's going to throw that one out the
window and therefore he won't know when
the writing is on the
wall they seek global
domination Martin it's a stated aim
that's why the Jesuits were
created and if they negate history and
think they've lost the plot and are now
just soup kitchen uh
organizers then they must think again so
the Roman Church is employing every
device to extend her influence and
increase her power in preparation for a
Fierce and determined conflict to regain
control over the world this comes from
the great controversy this is the book
which they hate which they say should
never be handed
out now I don't know what these people
are doing in the Adventist Church or why
they call themselves Adventists or
Adventist today because I'm also alive
today and I don't believe this nonsense
no do you believe it all not at all I
mean I believe what re Revelation 14 and
12 tells me yes and it's standing on two
legs to be a Seventh Day Adventist okay
and it totally negates the spirit of
Prophecy the spirit of Prophecy that one
is totally gone exactly so they won't
know what the writing on the world says
because they don't believe what the
prophet is
saying you know it's like uh we have 400
prophets all for us except for this one
and I hate him well in this case
her they want to take over the economy
making it impossible for us to do
business Martin have they ever read ROM
novarum probably not has rum novarum the
encyclical ever been ascended No in fact
uh Pope Francis is likes to quote Ram
noar every now and then okay all right
so he's obviously not very well informed
as far as these things
go and he causes all small and great
rich and poor free and slave to receive
a mark on their right hand or on their
foret uh Martin is that the first piece
or the second second beast that does
that the second beast so he's confused
cuz he's applying this to the first
Beast right but it is the mark of the
first Beast by its own definition now
I'm not here to tear it apart I'm just
saying that this individual has never
studied
Catholicism never he doesn't have a clue
as to what they teach or what they stand
for all right let's continue he says the
papac and with Satan these have one mind
there will be a universal Bond of Union
One great Harmony A Confederacy of
Satan's
forces the kings of the world will align
themselves with this Beast they will
give the power unto this system in other
words they will support its
Authority that's what the Bible
says and if this Authority is Manifest
in an individual
that stands for that
organization as an infallible
source and it negates the Commandments
of God does it not set aside the
authority of God completely does that
remove the relevance and the centrality
of Jesus Christ yes and shift it to man
yes in vain they worship me teaching for
Doctrine the Commandments of men is that
a Bible verse yes okay
so this is manifested the same arbitrary
oppressive power against religious
liberty freedom to worship God according
to the dictates of conscience as was
manifested by the papacy when in the
past it persecuted those who dared to
refuse to conform with the religious
rights and ceremonies of
romanism and this is again a
quote from Revelation chapter 17
now so what this Buton he's
saying that uh religious liberty is one
of the
horses that the papacy has saddled up it
is for religious
liberty but Martin don't they Define
their religious liberty that it has to
be in harmony with the common good
always and if it is not in harmony with
the common good you have no Liberty
that's it then you have no Liberty so
they're not for religious liberty
they're for religious bigotry true
because that's it I mean if you tell
somebody you're free except when you do
what I tell you to no only when I do
what I tell you to no except you're free
except when you don't do what I tell you
say that again so you are free except
when you don't do what I tell you to do
exactly then I'm going to bonx you on
your being yeah and I'm not going to to
do it I'm going to be clever as in the
Middle Ages I'm going to get the state
to do it for me yeah okay this is a very
dangerous situation to be in by the
way they have beautiful and complex
ceremonies that manipulate people the
pump and ceremony of the these are all
quotes Martin from the great controversy
so this person is using these quotes to
show that the people that believe these
quotes are bigots bigots yes the pump
and ceremony of the Catholic Worship has
a seductive bewitching Power by which
many are deceived and they come to look
upon the Roman Church as the very Gates
of Heaven now this was
written by a what this individual likes
to refer to someone from a Victorian age
they haven't got a clue about the modern
papers now I've got news for this
individual I was in the Vatican not so
long ago
and I stood there at a pillar when this
music and that Cho started singing and
the chanting and the the Ambiance was
going around and there was a visiting
priest there standing not too far from
me and he lifted up his hands like this
and he said this is the
kingdom and he slid down and went into a
virtual coma from
ecstasy uh he negates that I saw it with
my own eyes I would like to take this
individual to the Vatican and show him
the symbolism that is there and ask him
if he has any idea what it stands for
and if it really does stand for those
things wouldn't you want to hide it
instead of putting it in public
display all right and then let's
continue
they or at least their clergy are
immoral in unfolding the sins of his
life to a priest and earing sinful
mortal and too often corrupted with wine
and
Lous his standard of character is
lowered and is defiled in
consequence obviously this writer does
not agree with that
statement was he ever a Roman
Catholic I was now when I had a problem
and I had to get rid of something that
was bothering my conscience I knocked on
the door of the
priest and the door was opened and the
man was visibly inebriated sitting in
front of a bottle of
brandy that is the individual to whom I
had to confide my sins in order to get
rid of them I don't think this person
has any idea now let me be quite uh
fairh is it possible to knock on the
door of a Protestant pastor and find him
inebriated in front of a bottle of
brandy
definitely but do I have to confine my
sins in him in order to go to heaven no
no there is there a difference there is
a difference because and it's very
important to realize because that is
what the one system
requires the other one doesn't have it
no in fact they go so far as to say the
priest is an altar Christos yeah and he
is more powerful than God because he can
command God to come down and become part
of that bread so again it's not against
the individual it's the system okay they
plan to persecute
us she's piling up her lofty and massive
structures in the secret recesses of
which her former persecutions will be
repre great controversy Mery do do they
know the Jesuit
oath I don't think so and if they do
they probably just think oh what so what
yeah so all of this is not relevant none
of
it so let's say who the author is it's
Lauren cybal to easy he's the executive
editor of Adventist
today and he Compares this in a another
portion of this document to the
Holocaust and gives examples of evils in
other institutions including
protestantism and then he impin the
following opines gives his opinion he
says I'm
embarrassed fellow Adventists it is
downright embarrassing to continue our
campaign against Roman Catholics much
less to lead with that in our
evangelism just because a Victorian
woman
copied those prejudices from someone 150
some years ago Martin what is this man
or this
individual seeking in this
church I I believe he doesn't he totally
misses the relevance of the centrality
of Christ do you know how many false um
what a false accusation that is actually
it is it is uh well I don't want to I
don't want to say what I think it means
the copy portion that he's mentioning
there that in in today's day you can
actually if she was still alive or
anything you could be sued for
defamation let's not sue him because he
has a he has a record to face in the
books of Heaven now let me get back to
my
point you have a Protestant Pastor that
is trapped in pedophil
you have a Catholic priest that is
trapped in
pedophil both of them are equally guilty
and that's guilty before the law yes
does it change the centrality of Christ
no and that's where the Crux lies that's
where the Crux lies okay so just because
you find it in both
systems does that mean you can throw
Christ out and then go along with it can
you now say that the Protestant world is
as evil as the Catholic
world uh yes you can individuals but can
you say in their Doctrine and teaching
they are equally evil no you can't you
see he's totally missing the
point so he says
there and he calls that Adventist enough
of Adventist
bigotry yet Ellen White flies very close
to anti-semitism
Martin you just have to read the Bible
and you will see that the New Testament
flies very close to
anti-Semitism it blames the Jews for the
death of Christ but the pope exonerated
them and said it was the Romans but who
handed him over to the them over to the
Romans the Jews all right are there good
people amongst the Jews yes are there
bad people amongst the Jews yes are
there bad people in any race
gender whatever everywhere okay does
that affect the centrality of Christ no
are we sometimes bad people yes you
maybe but
me all right he saw the Covenant people
scattered in every land like wrecks in a
desert
Shore quoting The Desire of Ages so
despite headlines focusing on the priest
pedophile problem in the Roman Catholic
Church most American churches being hit
with child sexual abuse allegations are
Protestant is that the
point that's a diversion when you start
reasoning like this exactly so Martin
we're not doing this what's a Prof to
show up Adventist today or the
nonsensical argument that they are
providing
here the point is what is the
issue the issue is the relevance and the
centrality of Christ his kingdom and his
authority exactly that is the issue and
if it is
institutionalized in an
organization such as the Roman Catholic
system then you cannot align yourself
with it without disig yourself with
Christ and that is the point
okay let's take another article
that comes from this individual's
pen it's also Adventist today how
prophetic are
we as the
dispensationalists advanced their
eschatology we retreated into smug white
eyed
fear-mongering we went from the Biblical
teaching of Jesus returning someday we
hope soon to crying
persecution every time the pope has
heartburn
we have since failed to anticipate
anything meaningful the people of the
book haven't given prophetic guidance
concerning even one major event in the
20th and 21st
Century Two World Wars deaths estimated
at 50 to 80 million 50 million Dead from
the Spanish Flu nuclear stockpiles large
enough to destroy life on Earth climate
change the rise of Communism fascism
sides in Central Europe Russia turkey
Uganda Rwanda which one of those
bandwagons do you want to fly on exactly
so do you want the diversion do you want
to dilute the gospel and just focus on
one thing and you know what if I were
him I would choose one of them and say
you know this is my issue I'm going to
see to it that I'm going to defend the
cause of the Christians
in wherever
well the problem is he here is um
telling us that nowhere not one of these
were predicted by the people of the book
who's now supposed to be it's
irrelevant it's irrelevant we're dealing
with the centrality and the relevance of
Christ all right so Martin how important
is the centrality
of Christ and his dominion and rulership
and atonement in the Chinese
economy
[Music]
zero but but he mentions them here the
Chinese economic domination yeah but you
must remember now we supposed to um
predict these things through the Bible
That's according to him now because what
about Co and all of this you see the
Bible says there will be turmoil well he
actually
he's also going to um reference that
that we probably will be saying that oh
but this is all part of the end but it
is part of the end of course it's part
of the end so how do we
go not one was anticipated M there will
be famines there will be Wars there will
be rumors of wars pestilence they were
all
anticipated so he's never read his Bible
yeah he's never read his Bible okay
okay we told you things were going to be
bad but we didn't need cryptic
prophecies with numbers and Beasts for
that so God put them in the
Bible and God you were ignorant of what
really going on why did you put that
stuff in there because it's not
important we're not interested that's
exactly what he's actually saying you
can take Revelation T it te tear it out
of your Bible and throw it away because
we can just go to the gospel and Jesus
said it already so so Jesus that already
said in this world you will have trouble
so mostly As we watched people die by
the millions we muttered but just keep
your eye on the
Vatican we were supposed to watch
particularly two we are supposed to
watch all the signs in the world and
then we are to look at the Beast out of
the sea and out of the the Beast out of
the earth that's it there's a very clear
description of what they're going to do
and that writing I believe is appearing
on the wall but they've just thrown the
prophets out of the water and out of the
book negating them entirely so they
won't have a clue what's written on the
wall it's pretty clear what happened to
those they that drank out of that cup
with the false wine they fell with
Babylon they fell with them
okay all right Martin so they're going
to start legislating Sunday laws and
persecuting us that's a quote he's
mocking yeah is it in the documents of
the
225 yep H MH is it in there yes is it in
paper documents yes now I have a
question if a morality is going to be
legislated that is contrary to the
morality of Jesus
Christ then who will like
dictate such a
morality will it
be Elon
Musk no will it be B Gates
no will it be
ramapa no or will it be some religious
powerful Institute with
Worldwide networks yes can you expect a
worldwide religious Network to dictate
morality yes for sure can you yeah what
if that morality is contrary to the
morality and the centrality of
Christ then you're going to have a
problem and what if the kings of the
world choose to follow that morality
rather than the morality dictated by
Christ then you're going to be on the
short end of it so will they thereby be
saying Christ is not
relevant the one on the white throne in
Rome is relevant because he wrote an
encyclical has any
president or any Economist ever written
an encyclical
no
no never written an encyclical no okay
so where can we expect modal inputs for
society
from from an encyclical encyclical from
wres the encyclical the pope do you
think he actually pens it himself or do
you think the Beast has writers that put
their heads together to make sure that
they stay as apostate as
possible well probably that but I don't
know maybe he's got some direct channel
that he can use to write some of these
things they quote uh Thomas ainus and he
says it's okay to steal when you want to
all right so what the Three Angels means
in one of our recent Adventist today
Sabbath seminars one of my Seminary
professors said that when he preaches in
churches he often asks people do you
know what the Three Angels messages mean
can you explain them he seldom gets even
a single satisfying answer now that is
probably true mhm sadly s sadly because
many have lost the plot and cannot read
the writing on the wall the problem is
um if you've got thinking of throwing
the prophet out then you will and and
you don't it's not not studied anymore
in the
churches and I'm sad to say but but it's
because of Articles like this that it's
not studied anymore and now he wants to
group us with all others by saying
because we worship on the Sabbath we are
the the only church approved by God is
being
sarcastic no it is a
truth approved by God and those that
adhere to that truth if they happen to
be in that denomination fine there are
many in that denomination that don't
adhere to the truths in it like this
individual because obviously he's
rejected them
all that doesn't make the issue relevant
the point is the Sabbath for
example is it a command of Christ yes is
it his day and the paper say does it
have another day yes does it say that it
changed it yes does it say that it is a
mark of its Authority exactly is it
therefore a mark of its authority over
and above the relevance of Christ yes
that's the issue that's the issue why
understand it's the same with people
that says yeah but we why don't we we
can holy any day or every day exactly
but Jesus in Genesis already set aside
why why do we want to negate what Jesus
asked us okay now Martin was Jesus
a uh champion of the truth no
yes he he he was he popular no so when
he preached truth contrary to human
maxims was he persecuted yes now this
individual says over here we are to
separate ourselves from them and have
nothing at all to do with their
expressions of faith in fact they will
soon begin to persecute us because they
know that we're right and they're wrong
Martin I will say only those who
recognize that they can have nothing to
do with
them because their doctrines negate the
re relevance of Christ will be
persecuted he probably won't be because
he will align himself with their
thinking look you're going to have to
stand
strong to be persecuted if I can almost
say it like that exactly you're going to
have to really stand strong if you are
going to be persecuted not going you
have to stand strong when you are going
to be persecuted you have to stand
strong so that you can be persecuted so
so that you will be persecuted let's put
it that way were the reformers
persecuted because they refused to
accept the mass yeah yes they refuse to
accept
transubstantiation
Okay uh would you under due rest accept
transubstantiation I hope by God I won't
okay all right so you don't want to
accept TR substantiation what if you
were forced to say Christ never bore
your sins you will pay for them in
purgatory would you prepared to stand
and say though the heavens fall I will
not move from this position with God as
my help yes because if I accept your
position then I've negated the
centrality and the atonement of Christ
would you say that yes what about the
Sabbath same same thing so what is the
issue is it uh this political rambling
here or is it the centrality of Christ
and his authority no matter what the
issue it's a principle it's about the
relevance of Christ and how far would
you go to stand for him
exactly all right Martin so having said
that let's move into current
events now here we have a speech made by
Donald Trump and let's just hear what he
has to say this is not to condemn this
is to
inform let's hear what he has to say we
will not stand for any attacks against
judge Barrett's Faith anti-catholic
bigotry has absolutely no place in the
United States of America it predominates
in the Democrat party and we must do
something immediately about it like a
republican win and let's make it a
really big
one okay
Martin from a worldly point of
view if you had
no background knowledge of of the issue
and the war regarding the centrality of
Christ would you go along with his
speech Yes yes yeah because it's it's
logical logical it's logical what is
this anti-catholic bias it's bigotry
yeah didn't that uh Adventist today
author use the same
word he echoing he's echoing what the
president is saying in other words he's
on that wavelength yes now I can
understand the wavelength me too I can
understand the wavelength if you have
zero knowledge of what the scripture
says what the reformers taught what
prophecy says and why yeah then I can
understand that mindset and the mindset
that we are standing for now must be
called bigotry yes
that is exactly but that is also where
this comes in then all right but what
if what if the scriptures are spot on
what if the prophetic utterances are
spot on what if the reformers were spot
on and what if the spirit of Prophecy is
spot on MH and the issue is the
centrality and authority of Christ then
his speech is based on
misinformation so what is it based on
social Doctrine social issues does the
Catholic Church take care of sick people
in their hospitals yes do they have soup
kitchens do the Jesuits even run those
organizations yes do they have
universities many do they push a certain
ideology in those universities
was he subject to that ideology are his
children subject to that ideology is his
cabinet subject to that ideology yes
everyone is the people yeah the cabinet
people working in his government at this
stage is the world in an ecumenical
climate yes is the Reformation pushed
aside yes has the rift been
closed definitely the hand has stretched
the gulf across the gulf all right so
Martin what has been pushed aside the
centrality of Christ the centrality of
Christ has been set aside now if we
could sit down and explain it to him
using scripture and scripture
alone a detailed study of Daniel chapter
7 Revelation 1314 and 17 plus all the
history that God with it looking at the
secret
societies the power that they wield
their ecumenical drive any Drive of
ecumenicism removes the centrality of
Christ because his authority is negated
for a worldly Authority that's the issue
and it makes it difficult because people
will see it oh but you think you're
better than the rest all right so I
agree that if you say the papacy is the
Antichrist because there are pedophiles
in it yeah uh there
are uh transgenders in
it there are drunkards in it there are
rapists in
it that's not the point no that's not
true either that's not why they are
Antichrist that's not why they
Antichrist no but the fact is there are
such individuals in that organization
and in Protestant organizations and any
other religion and any secret society
and even in God's professed Church
exactly
so that's not the point point what is
the point all right but if you look at
these things could you be swept away
that's the thing then you will have you
will write articles like that because
isn't there a mission for the people
that really know all right and the
religions want to unite and they want to
have an authoritative figure and the
papacy fits now yeah well if I mean what
I just meant but what I'm saying is if
you want to say that it's a problem in
the way that people are bigots against
Catholics then you don't understand like
you've just said understand there
Mission if you know the truth you must
bring that truth to these people and
what if you have have people's interests
at
heart wouldn't you want to shout it to
them so that they could understand
exactly did the reformers preach yes
didn't they virtually conquer the
world all right now here is an article
in the independent and it says Satanist
Church holds drive to collect socks for
the
homeless a Satanist organ organization
in Florida has launched a sock drive for
the homeless as part of long running
campaign its mission statement says the
mission of the satanic temple is to
encourage benevolence and empathy
amongst all people reject tyranny
Authority Advocate practical common
sense and Justice and be directed by the
human conscience to undertake Noble
Pursuits Guided by the individual
will people don't understand that within
this massive organization you have
satanists and you have
luciferians the one worships the Light
Side the other one worships the dark
dark side but the light side will give
the dark sides
knighthoods right let's just phrase it
like that so there's an organization
that teaches and preaches and has to
according to their Doctrine
practice
benevolence do you think Donald Trump
would go down well if he said we have to
stop anti- satanic temple
bigotry
no why not they're doing good things
Martin that is exactly the problem
because they they are against uh their
thinking of religion let's ask another
question who are his advisers Catholics
most of them and evangelicals actually
ecumenical he's got an ecumenical
advisory all right do you think he has
many representatives from the Church of
Satan in his inner core advisory
panel I don't think so you don't think
so do you understand my point yeah this
this individual who was writing that
article in Adventist today looks at
these issues and says we're bigots if
you attack Catholics because look at all
the good things that they are doing
exactly but look at all the good things
that these people are doing and then you
say but they also do evil things well
the Catholics do Protestants too the
mission statement of this satanic temple
it sounds the same as a Protestant and
Catholic mission statement might even
sound better it might even sound better
is the centrality of Christ in this no
for sure not all right is it therefore
an issue in the choice that you make yes
would you choose
these no why
not because it doesn't fit well and it
removes the centrality of CH for sure
for us but I mean normal people will
this is just to show you how logical or
illogical reasoning is the reasoning is
totally illogical all right so now now
what if the organization that they
really do follow and make their main uh
speakers at events like an
inauguration what if they are just as
anti the centrality of Christ but just
couch it in religious terms shouldn't
that be exposed for sure and that's why
it's so will you be in an ecumenical
council with them as well with the I
don't think so no it wouldn't work
although in practice you might because
if you go to a rock concer you are
worshiping this
entity or a rave concert it's exactly or
many a Christian concert yeah all right
but Francis has United the world against
himself this is an article from February
1425 it's actually sort of a tongue and
cheek article isn't
it in nearly 12 years since inauguration
Pope Francis has received praise and
criticism in almost equal measure for
his outspoken stance on political issues
in francis's most recent intervention
into the world of Politics the pope sent
a letter to American Bishops on Tuesday
condemning United States President
Donald Trump's Mass deportation program
is it a social issue or a religious
issue
social president Donald Trump's Mass
deportation program was the issue right
so what is built on the basis of force
and not on truth about the equal Dignity
of every human being begins badly and
will end badly he letter read Trump's
bordar Tom homman who is Catholic said
franchis should stick to the Catholic
church and fix that and leave border
enforcement to us with supporters of the
president taking to social media to
issue similar
criticism let's say Martin that the
pendulum has moved to the right mhm and
some of the liberal thinking of Francis
is now not popular with the right right
yeah
okay what
if in some future event there should be
another Pope that would upset some uple
carts because many believe this is the
last Pope right uh I don't necessarily
believe that wouldn't it be interesting
if there would be a very
conservative voice Rising within the
Catholic Church it will really put the
cat among the amongst the pigeons all
right now one of the individuals that
Donald Trump just made his
representative in
Hollywood uh is a very
conservative Catholic Catholic who is
also a raid against the doctrines of
Francis so that ideology is Raising its
head it's pretty strong you know what's
interesting even though he's such a
liberal and he's do all of these things
whenever confronted with it he's still
he still goes back to the conservative
side all right now what if the
evangelicals were to say we have to uh
unify and strengthen the Christian
position right mhm that means elevating
one religion over the others in their
environment yes and one of the ways in
which we could do that would be uh to
keep Sunday again so that people can go
to church and can reflect on spiritual
things and spend time with the family
Etc do you think the papacy according to
its encyclicals and
dogmas would support such a view oh for
sure definitely okay how would that
affect the centrality of Christ and his
law well it will be seeming that it is
for him but it's actually putting him
completely out of the picture out of the
picture and accepting the authority of
Rome yes
okay now let's listen to what to what
the man had to say about Pope Francis
look at how it words for the pope Pope
want fix the Catholic church I'm saying
this is a lifelong Catholic I was
baptized Catholic I first communion as a
Catholic Confirmation as a Catholic he
ought to fix the Catholic church and
concentrate on on his work and Lead
border enforcement to us he wants to
attack us from securing our border he's
got to wall around the Vatican does he
not so he's got to wall around protect
his people and himself but we can't have
a wall around United States so I wish he
stick to the Catholic church and fix
that and leave border enforcement to us
question
Martin is he anti- a sentiment of the
Pope regarding the issue or is he anti-
Catholic anti against a sentiment of the
Pope aha because he how many times did
he say there what a stor Catholic
actually is correct so this is not
against Catholicism this is in harmony
with Catholicism so any any voice that
comes out of Catholicism that is
doctrinal would he not be on the
bandwagon for sure he and that's why
actually that emphasizes why the people
are so or the Conservative Catholics are
so riled up with Pope Francis because he
doesn't according to them stick to the
real Catholic Doctrine exactly all right
here's a Catholic news agency article
which is interesting pop Francis and
Vance Clash over Ordo amorus Vance a
Catholic is he anti- Catholic no what's
he clashing with with the sentiment of
right would he would he clash with any
of the other doctrinal issues no for
sure and if Francis was doing according
to them the the thing according to what
the Catholics want them you know that
the doctrine they wouldn't have a
problem they wouldn't have a problem all
right so V Catholic had in a late
January interview invoked an old school
Christian concept he later identified as
the Ordo amorus which he says teaches
that one's
compassion belongs first to one's family
and fellow citizens
and then after that to the rest of the
world it's something that happens in an
airplane every single time you fly when
that O oxygen mask comes down please fix
it to your own face before you help
those around you it's
logical so love your family and then
love your neighbor and then you love
your community and then you love your
fellow CI
in your own country and after that you
can focus on prioritize the rest of the
world writing through the US Bishops on
the topic of migration the pope wrote
February 10 that an authentic rule of
law is verified precisely in the
dignified treatment that all people
deserve uh dignified treatment of
people and illegal
activities like forcing your way into a
country
illegally uh what has that got to do
with the issue you are transgressing the
law finished and therefore you have
become a transgressor of the law and
that is called the criminal that's how
it works and then you must be treated
like a criminal but it seems to me that
not only on this issue but on many
issues rape or whatever or even murder
uh
the absolute rule of law has been put
aside these people are roaming the
streets yeah and that's why you have the
chaos that you have but again that's not
the point the point we're making is is
it a social
issue the whole time or is it a dogmatic
religious issue no it's all have to do
with social and this is why like we've
seen in the article of Adventist
today it's Divergent it's diverting you
from the centrality of the central issue
so in other
words if you regulate orderly and legal
migration then that is the right of a
government that's what van said and he
said to the pope you know with all your
sympathies and whatever you have for
these poor people etc etc you know stick
to your
business Trump says he's ordering
attorney general to Target
anti-christian bi us with religious
liberty task force now it gets
interesting Martin I see writing on the
wall because the
Constitution gives equal rights to all
religious systems right this is already
treading
on completely negating that okay he told
prayer breakfast attendees that his
administration would also work to
protect Christians in our schools in our
military in our government in our
workplaces hospitals and in our public
squares and bring our country back
together as one nation under God with
liberty and justice for
all is there a Christian bias here yes
okay but Trump and his supporters have
long pushed for
Christianity especially Evangelical and
fundamentalist strains of Christianity
to occupy a privileged place in American
society is that what the great
controversy is predicting yes is that
what Revelation chap 13 is predicting
definitely now whose morality will get
this privileged place the Catholic
churches exactly exactly now let's just
look at this issue welcome back
president Trump is taking action to
combat what he calls anti-christian bias
in the US during a series of events in
Washington last week surrounding the
National Prayer Breakfast he signed an
executive order establishing a new task
force to eliminate anti-christian
discrimination within the federal
government the executive order
highlights an increase in vandalism
targeting conservative churches and
pro-life pregnancy centers following the
Supreme Court's overturning of roie Wade
at the prayer breakfast last week Trump
criticized the Department of Justice the
IRS and the FBI by name he appointed
attorney general Pam Bondi to lead that
task force which will identify unlawful
policies and practices across federal
agencies and recommend further
presidential or legislative action it
will also focus on investigating and
Prosecuting cases of anti-christian
violence and
vandalism well um in the white house we
will protect Christians in our schools
in our military in our government in our
workplaces hospitals and in our public
squares and we will bring our country
back together as one nation under God
with liberty and justice for
all in addition Trump is Reviving The
White House Faith office to be led by
Pastor Paula White who previously
advised him on faith initiatives during
his first term a senior adviser tells
CBN that Trump has specifically directed
The Faith office to be located in the
West Wing the the task force launches
following Trump's pardon of pro-life
activists charged under the Biden
Administration and after a 2023 house
report revealed an FBI memo targeting
traditional Catholics as domestic
threats Gary well I think it needed to
be done because sadly and unfortunately
we have uh a great deal of evidence that
under the prior Administration and in
some elements of the
bureaucracy uh the Christians and people
of Faith were being Target
uh we know that the Richmond FBI office
in coordination with other uh offices uh
the Richmond Virginia office in
coordination with other entities
throughout the FBI was suggesting that
uh faithful traditionalist Roman
Catholics should be surveilled as a
potential domestic security threat uh we
know that uh the Department of Justice
targeted parents whose only crime was to
attend school board meetings uh and
object uh to uh the teaching of the
trans agenda to their children and boys
using girls bathrooms they were targeted
I mean boys using girls bathrooms they
were targeted for surveillance and
potential arrest and prosecution so we
need to make sure the Christians are not
being persecuted that they're not being
targeted and that the bureaucracy is not
violating their first amendment rights
and that is why
today I'm on and really honoring a lot
of people but I'm announcing that I will
be creating a brand new presidential
commission on religious liberty it's
going to be a very big deal which will
work tirelessly to uphold this most
fundamental
right quite elderly woman would be put
in jail for praying here in America she
was put in jail cuz she was
praying but were joined today by a woman
who was 75 years old poet harlo was
sentenced to two years in prison for
peacefully praying outside of a clinic
charged under an obscure law that hadn't
been used in years selectively
weaponized against Christians by the
previous
administration now Martin it is
true that there has been an
anti-christian bias that's true that's
correct correct right mhm okay so these
organizations that is now formed M are
they government organizations yes this
is a government or the task force will
they have clout will will policing be
involved to make sure this doesn't
happen yes okay that sounds pretty good
right well it's church and state coming
together ah is that writing on the wall
yes
church and state coming
together did Vance in a recent speech in
Europe reprimand the UK for example for
arresting people for praying silently in
their minds
yeah and are they actually thinking
about it and saying you know the man
actually has a point
MH will America become prescriptive in
the world regarding these issues we can
see it okay is that writing on the wall
here yes
do you think many people are reading the
writing on the wall or don't they
understand it or can't they even see it
they can't even see it they are excited
to hear when um Trump is implementing or
putting a task force like this because
at
last it will be sorted out the
Christians will have their place all
right now let me ask you something very
strange now the previous President Joe
Biden was he a Catholic yes was he a
stone Catholic yes at the end of his
presenc he did he go and visit the pope
yes well just before he stepped out of
office all right there were some
controversies some Bishop said you know
he shouldn't receive Mass but uh again
he was allowed to receive Mass etc
etc there was some controversy around it
did he become a Freemason right there at
the end yes or did he acknowledge being
a
Freemason I don't know right we don't
know
all right what about this statement in
14 manuscripts release this terrible
picture drawn by John to show how
completely the powers of Earth will give
themselves over to evil should show
those who have received the truth how
dangerous it is to link up with secret
societies or to join themselves in any
way with those who do not keep God's
Commandments uh secret societies does
that include organization that have
secret Oaths yeah do the Jesuits have
secret Oaths yes do the Knights of Malta
have secret Earths
yep Martin do do you think upus day has
secret Oaths do you think the Freemasons
have secret Oaths definitely they all
have secret Oaths
right uh all the Catholic organization
are they vying for Catholic Supremacy
yes definitely they pretty successful if
you think about all these people in the
administration yep yeah the
representation on in the administration
on the courts in everywhere on a
Freemason altar do you have all the
religious books on there do you have the
Sarita do you have the Quran do you have
the tanak do you have the Bible yes you
have them all so they're ecumenical M if
you are
ecumenical and you are join Jo up with
religions that negate the centrality of
Christ don't they then negate the
relevance of Christ
yeah so Martin who is
your moral
Beacon when you an ecumenical set no
your model Beacon mine is Jesus
Christ yours is Jesus Christ what if
this model Beacon's attributes
clash with those that are being
propagated in the world what then then
I'm going to be in a clash with the
world then you're on a Clash of Minds
yeah but you belong to Clash of Minds
don't
[Laughter]
you is this statement a
warning definitely it's a warning
right so Martin let's end with our work
is an aggressive
one and I'll admit we were probably
in the eyes of many aggressive in this
talk for sure we will probably get a lot
of comments telling us that we were
antagonistic towards people and it
should have been done with more love but
Martin who are we
defending Christ
Christ and his centrality and his
kingdom yeah and his law for sure if you
love me keep my Commandments
yes that you may have the right to the
tree of life is that also in
Revelation here are they that keep the
Commandments verily my sabbaths you
shall keep we could go on and on and on
we don't have to do that our Warfare is
aggressive because we are soldiers of
Jesus that's it now if you are a soldier
for
Jesus then the relevance and the
centrality of Christ is your aim
and anything that negates
it or diminishes it is your enemy and
that's how it is okay we must bear the
bloodstained banner into the very
strongholds of the enemy we have to
preach these things uh are we going to
strap bombs to us and blow ourselves up
no what's the point yeah you're not
going to do much preaching after that
yeah it'll be all over
right so what's your weapon the Bible
this one yeah is this your B is this
your weapon that's the only weapon is
the only weapon
okay but if I may just quickly
intervene it's a two-edged sword it must
cut you too yeah it must cut me as well
all right we wrestle not against flesh
and
blood but against principalities against
Powers against the rulers of the
darkness of this world we're dealing
with a demonic mindset that has been
around since the fall of Adam that's
it again spiritual wickedness in high
places spiritual
wickedness if we Will consent to lay
down our arms to lower the bloodstained
banner to become the captives and
Servants of
Satan and he's an enemy of the law of
God right he hates the law of God
it we may be released from the conflict
and the suffering he will leave us
alone if you are chained to his Chariot
he'll give you a measure of Peace yeah
but this peace will be gained only at
the loss of Christ and Heaven this is a
serious warning to those that write
articles like we read in the beginning
that is why it might seem harsh
but it's a case of life and death
correct I certainly have nothing against
the brother but I have a lot against his
dogmas for sure we cannot accept peace
on such conditions Let It Be war war to
the end of Earth's history rather than
peace through apostasy and sin
amen that is our message and that is the
prophet that helps us to understand the
writing on the wall we need to
understand the writing this is what it
says and you know what as that finger is
writing
there and people are sitting with wine
glasses full of
Abominations and drinking them out of
socalled not even literal like in the
time of balasa
socalled holy chots
it's it's a
disgrace we need to understand the
Reformation or as Graton Guin
said that church of England historian in
the late
1800s he said or else we will have to
fight the Reformation all over again and
his words have come true let's
pray Heavenly Father the issue is the
relevance of Christ the issue is his
centrality the issue is his authority
and his
law and the world is negating it by
creating
liazon in such a fashion that he is
removed as the Cornerstone but if you
reject the
Cornerstone the whole building
collapses Lord Lord Open the
Eyes of the people that they may see is
my prayer in jesus' name amen amen
[Music]